you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen foreign of Jahannam
president Carnegie Mellon University
[Applause]
well good afternoon okay we're gonna try
this again good afternoon
Oh much better much better it is my
great pleasure to extend a warm welcome
to all of you as we kick off this
inaugural CMU K&L gates conference on
ethics and artificial intelligence
before I get started we pick this date
in April because we knew that this would
be the third week of spring and
especially for many of our friends and
colleagues from the Bay Area from the
west coast and from Texas we knew that
you wanted to enjoy spring in Pittsburgh
so you are welcome really happy to
welcome all of you on behalf of my
colleagues at Carnegie Mellon we're
joined here today by several of our
trustees and members of the university
leadership team and by a wide array of
distinguished CMU faculty and thought
leaders from across the country you will
hear from them throughout the day today
and tomorrow as one of Carnegie Mellon's
newest initiatives and annual traditions
this conference brings together thought
leaders from diverse perspectives to
discuss the ethical social and policy
ramifications brought on by advances in
artificial intelligence and
computational technologies this two-day
event has been made possible by an
exceptional coalition of support first I
want to take a moment to thank our ex
ordinary partners at K&L gates ever
since we began discussing the
possibility of this new form I've been
impressed by the thought and foresight
of our K&L gates partners who understood
the far-reaching the effects of these
new technologies not only in the legal
world but also throughout society and
they've been willing to invest in work
to make sure that these technologies and
these unprecedented vance's that we see
benefit society and benefits humanity
because of their generosity can all
gates Endowment for Ethics and
computational technologies will advance
research and education in this critical
domain and foster dialogues like this
week's conference I'm delighted to
welcome several representatives from K&L
gates this afternoon including Jim
Segura Dahle global managing partner who
will provide remarks in just a few
minutes
Michael cutsies chairman of the
management committee and david lehman
partner and co head of the K&L gates
artificially intelligent initiative and
I should note that Michael is also a
proud CMU alone Dietrich
a college class of 82 Michael was 10
years old when he graduated from college
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming and thanking all of our
partners from K&L gates
[Applause]
I'm also police to acknowledge all of
our conference speakers and panelists
including my friend Eric Horvitz
director of Microsoft Research Lab who
is here today as our distinguished
speaker for this event welcome Eric pre
praying such an extraordinary agenda
requires exceptional leadership so I'm
grateful to the conference organizers
the steering committee and of course my
colleagues the co-chairs David Danks and
Eleanor Bach
finally this conference has been
supported by countless professionals
including dorothy robinson of counsel at
K&L gates and the entire planning
committee at carnegie mellon and at kano
gates please join me in thanking all of
our special guests as well as our
conference organizers there is little
doubt that emerging technologies and
artificial intelligence or at the center
of an ongoing economic and societal
transformation that will no doubt will
continue for decades to come as we
embrace the Internet of Things
unprecedented access to massive amount
of data and the rise of automation and
robotics we're barreling toward a future
run by cyber enabled systems while these
technologies will enhance our comfort
security and quality of life for society
for for all of us their deployment has
had unprecedent consequences for our
workforce our education system
potentially for social justice for
fairness for privacy and many other
aspects of society the effect of
technology on society is not a brand new
concern but as we see these emerging
technologies pervade every aspect of our
lives and disrupt markets and disrupt
industries these issues have become even
more urgent
consider for a moment a few phenomena
Mokhtar technology-driven world as data
has become a new currency for business
and for technology we're seeing a
dramatic surge in the collection storage
analysis and monetization of our
personal and often most sensitive data
meanwhile the most cherished attributes
of the internet and the web its speed
its reach its openness and the notion of
anonymity are being used to undermine
our democracy and our civil liberties as
AI enhances and augments and in some
cases outpaces human capabilities human
machine interaction is reimagining the
future of work at the same time the very
nature of employment is involving skill
cycles are shorter than ever before
consider for a moment that according to
a recent study 65% of the jobs that
generation Z will perform don't even
exist today this will have dramatic
implications for educating the next
generation it's not just a scale and
ubiquity of these advances that are
remarkable the pace of advances as well
as the acceleration of their economic
impact is also unparalleled in human
history as an example it took landline
phones about 45 years to go from 5
percent to 50 percent penetration among
US households by comparison smart phones
went from 5 percent to 40 percent in
about just 4 years and that was during a
recession and in 2017 that number
reached more than 77 percent today we're
at an inflection point for the
proliferation of AI robotics and
automation as this innovation moves
forward at warp speed our deployment of
ethics our development of ethics I
should say
policy must keep up now of course is a
time for partners from across public and
private sectors to come together with
effective communities to ensure that
technology is used to benefit humanity
individually of course as well as the
entire society as the University that
has been intimately involved in the
creation and evolution of artificial
intelligence we've definitely been
responsible for some really
groundbreaking innovations but we've
also built an interdisciplinary culture
focused on making sure that
technological progress benefits society
through our partnerships we're K&L gates
as well as our block Center for
technology and society which we just
recently launched CMU and our
collaborators are helping to shape the
world in which people policy and
technology are better connected some of
CMU's most passionate partners have been
right here in Pittsburgh which has been
serving as a living laboratory for
technology that is integrated with
society our Mayor Bill Peduto has been
at the forefront of these collaborative
efforts and has established himself as a
national leader in progressive inclusive
and sustainable innovation of American
societies I'm delighted that he's able
to join us today to offer a few words
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming Pittsburgh Mayor Bill Peduto
[Applause]
Thank You mr. president and thank you to
Carnegie Mellon University and K&L gates
for taking on this issue and being able
to have a discussion and I also want to
thank the person who wrote this speech
for me because it's one of the best
political speeches that I've not going
to read I always try to speak off the
cuff so let me explain what these next
two days mean for policy makers you know
Pittsburgh was an industry leader right
the industrial revolution during World
War two we produced more steel than
Germany in Japan combined and when we
built out this industry in this great
wealth that came to this region it came
at a very heavy cost we had air that was
dangerous to breathe we had water that
was poisonous to drink and we had the
greatest disparity between the people
who worked in those mines and mills and
those that owned and operated them the
greatest disparity in American history
and those were the costs that came with
it and it would take decades and decades
to be able to change that what we did
what Pittsburghers do we created the
first Clean Air Act in American history
and we went about to clean our air we
created public/private partnerships in
order to be able to clean our water and
we organized in those mines and in those
mills and in the process of building
America every Bridge and every
skyscraper we created the middle class
but they came as afterthoughts to the
Industrial Revolution not a component of
the Industrial Revolution
so as we find ourselves today in the
fourth Industrial Revolution we have to
look beyond simply what this technology
can provide the venture capitalists out
of California we have to think about
what it will provide to the people who
live in cities throughout
country we went through decades of
redlining out neighborhoods based upon
race and based upon income we cannot
read line out communities in this new
economy
based on whether or not you have a
cellphone
whether you or not you have credit we
have to be able to make sure everybody
is having that same opportunity and the
technology will help us to expand it we
have to look beyond just what the
technology will do in stark tech
understand how it can minimize negative
effects to the environment and we have
to look and see how it will enhance the
places we call home in Pittsburgh we
call it P for people planet Place and
performance a new metric for a 21st
century not old economics of the 19th
century a quadruple bottom line of being
able to understand how to measure
success and for policymakers it's
absolutely critical because when we look
at the ethics of where AI can take us
it goes beyond purchasing drones for a
city that will come up with issues of
privacy or being able to throw a drone
behind a wall and having somebody have
already have programmed when it takes a
human life at what point then do we
start to think about creating machines
and algorithms that have the ability to
take a human life we are at the
forefront of all of this coming together
and it's coming together so fast but if
we don't plan for the negative
consequences in the beginning
we'll have made the mistake that we made
in the industrial revolution and we will
spend decades trying to solve those
problems
[Applause]
thank you very much bill for your
leadership and for making Pittsburgh be
such an inclusive community I'm happy to
share with you that later this evening
we'll will celebrate the first two
recipients of new professorships funded
through their K&L gates endowment these
recipients exemplify interdisciplinary
nature of these complex issues
the first is illenore Bock who is an
expert of course in our computer science
school while the other Molly write
Stinson investigates past and present
implications of AI and computation on
design and architecture with
appointments in our School of Design and
our school of architecture in addition
the K&L Gates Presidential fellowship
endowed fund will support for
outstanding doctoral students veronica
Allante Zachary and Abigail whom you'll
meet later today whose work spans
information systems Computer Science
Engineering public policy and social and
decision science I'm delighted to
congratulate these pioneering scholars
on their prestigious professorship and
scholarship please join me in
congratulating all day awardees
[Applause]
as I mentioned earlier we are truly
fortunate to have K&L gates as our
partner who's generous support will help
us who helped put us at the center of
some of the most pressing conversations
facing society at this time it is my
great pleasure to introduce Jim Sagar
Dahl as global managing partner he
serves as a firm's chief executive
officer and native Pittsburgher so you
can tell you all about the weather
Jim is a board member of the Allegheny
Conference for Community Development
please join me in extending him a warm
welcome to Jim Hall Thank You President
Cheney and I'm thrilled to be here it's
very exciting event just terrific to be
in the company of so many brilliant
people working on truly important
matters I am pleased and honored to
welcome all of you to the first
inaugural conference of ethics and
artificial intelligence which I am proud
to say is funded by the kano Gates
Endowment for Ethics and computational
technologies with this initiative we
honor not only our long-standing
relationship with CMU but also the
commitment of both organizations to be
at the forefront in furthering the
understanding of the opportunities and
the challenges presented by the
ever-evolving role of Technology in our
society including the role of artificial
intelligence machine learning and
robotics our law firm has had a long
relationship with CMU over many decades
that relationship has been a source of
tremendous pride for us although our
core missions are different we have
worked together shared civic involvement
and even shared leaders for example one
of my predecessors as Managing Partner
of kano Gates Chuck Queenan is a former
chair of the board at CMU he's currently
an emeritus trustee of the University
continues to provide wisdom and guidance
to both of our organizations with this
conference we have added another
dimension to that relationship as you
know it will be a biennial event and
will be an opportunity that we hope will
stimulate great discussion and important
dialogue you might reasonably ask why is
the field of ethics and intelligence
artificial intelligence important decay
no gates a law firm that's a reasonable
question our firms work and our
footprint is global as well as national
we like to think that we are a leader in
the practice of law as it relates to
technology innovation and development
we're fortunate to represent some of the
leading technology entities in the world
as well as numerous startup companies
that aspire to be in that sphere we care
about what our clients care about and
forward-looking clients everywhere care
about artificial intelligence and its
potential impact on their businesses and
society at large evidence of this is the
fact that our artificial intelligence
practice area now comprises over 80
lawyers the legal app the legal
implications of the application of AI on
our clients is broad deep and
interdisciplinary it will affect
numerous different practice areas for us
and for clients around the world
including mergers and acquisitions
healthcare the protection of
intellectual property employment law and
a host of regulatory issues further the
practice of law itself is undergoing
major shifts in AI increasingly will be
important to how legal services are
delivered to clients we approach what we
do in a forward-looking way with a
forward-looking mindset that's part of
our DNA and that's why we're so excited
to be part of this important discussion
and exchange of ideas all of us know
that advancements and computer related
technologies many of them born of
research here at Carnegie Mellon
University going back to her
Simon and his colleagues will
increasingly bring about profound
changes that affect our society and
humanity in many ways we can see that a
critical dimension to many of the
choices that will have to be made
whether implicitly or explicitly as
technology is developed is the ethical
dimension and this is going to be
important as our policymakers grapple
with difficult issue as time goes on and
as advances are made we all have a stake
in the outcome of these discussions
getting the best minds from across the
relevant fields of study from robotics
to philosophy in between and around to
focus on these problems is essential to
address in these matters efficiently and
ethically in making our gift to fund an
endowment and ethics and computational
technologies we made an investment for
the long term in an area important to us
as a law firm into society at large with
this conference we are pleased to open
this new forum for discussion and
development of the important work of the
speakers and participants welcome and I
hope you enjoy and benefit from the
conference
[Applause]
Thank You President Joe Haney and mr.
Sager doll and Mayor Peduto I'm David
Danks Thurston professor of philosophy
and psychology here at CMU and co-chair
of this event with Eleanor Bosch
currently professor of robotics for
about another two hours at which point
he becomes the inaugural K&L gates
professor of ethics and computational
technologies and it is our great
pleasure to welcome you all to this
inaugural conference on ethics and AI
here in Pittsburgh I want to say a few
words about why this conference needs to
happen now and why it has to have the
format that it has no doubt you're all
well aware that artificial intelligence
has reached fever pitch in society today
thanks to certain companies what they've
done in terms of rushing forth with
deployments in the real world and thanks
to discourse by outstanding
investigative journalists who have
turned the public's attention to these
issues but the people in this room know
something else because many of our
friends who are here from policy makers
to business folks to researchers are
flying around the world at a breakneck
pace now between meetings and other
meetings discussing regulation
discussing entrepreneurship and venture
capital funding to AI discussing the
question of how we engineer ethics into
artificial intelligence systems and all
those meetings are fantastic and must
happen but this meeting has to happen
because there's a fundamental question
that is actually inherently
transdisciplinary what will artificial
intelligence do to our sense of human
identity what will we be in the age that
we can see already on the horizon that's
the fundamental question of identity and
the fundamental question of human
dignity and those are the issues that we
will grapple with during this conference
so we've designed a conference for you
that brings together outstanding
journalists and experts and sets them up
not to talk within Disciplinary confines
but rather to talk in a
transdisciplinary
manner about the core issues of identity
of humanity itself that's a conversation
that we think has to start now
has to repeat over and over again so
that's the conversation that you're part
of and that we're very happy to welcome
you to but enough about the highfalutin
stuff some logistical notes very quickly
you'll notice on all of the tables that
there are cubes that have the schedule
have information about Wi-Fi for those
who are interested in that Twitter
hashtag and so forth throughout the the
conference over the next two days there
will be opportunities for you as members
of the audience to participate in terms
of providing questions for panelists to
answer that will all be done using a
technology refer to a slide Oh an app
and there will be some more information
provided about that as we get to the
first panel the conference is being
live-streamed so if there are people
that you know wanted to participate but
we're unable to be here please let them
know about that
and the conference elements will all
over the coming weeks be rolled out on
the webpage so we encourage you to
continue to look back at that ok back to
the important things this conference as
ela said is about having a conversation
of the ways that technology particularly
AI and robotic technologies are
influencing impacting providing
opportunities and challenges for us
humans for societies for nations for
peoples and in particular we've decided
to organize this conference around four
different sessions each of which is
anchored in a particular human interest
or human value so rather than having a
session on AI and self-driving cars we
have sessions on equity of access and
equity of impact trust policy and
governance and agency and empowerment
which we hope will help to focus the
interdisciplinary and transdisciplinary
and multidisciplinary conversations
around these core human values and
interests so that we can start to make
real progress over the course of the
coming days and so with that said I'd
like to turn things over to ela to
introduce the first session thank you
David
session 1 we're gonna dive right into
this equity of access and they could
impact so let me just say 30 seconds
about that what are the interesting
things about artificial intelligence and
computational technologies writ large is
that they can increase the apparent
productivity of human society they can
allow us to do more they can allow us
new kinds of discoveries new spaces to
in which we can discover and create new
knowledge the challenge with that form
of innovation is of course stemming from
the fact that AI and information itself
has ownership and as a result as you
create new AI technologies new
innovations you have the danger that you
can limit the access to that AI
technology to the few you have the
further danger that you can in fact
augment the wealth of the few through
those very same technologies thus
increasing disparity between the those
who have and those who have not so
fundamentally we have on the one hand
technology that can make the world a
better place
on average the same time we have a
technology that while the average case
might be better
the extrema might be far worse and so
that fundamental challenge in terms of
both access and in terms of how the
world as a whole is impacted by AI
that's the focus of our first session
now each of our sessions is structured
differently so we think you're gonna
enjoy that there are spotlight speakers
there are videos that help to set the
stage and there are panel discussions in
this session we're gonna start with a
video and I'm going to ask to Q that
right away and then I'll introduce the
spotlight speaker to get things started
so let's run with the video please
we really as engineers need to take
responsibility to work on the things
that will make the world a better place
taking responsibility having a research
strategy instead of just going wherever
your curiosity takes you AI and
optimization have very different
strengths than humans do humans are
really good at actually figuring out
what the ins are what the value
judgments are in general how it should
trade-off between different things like
various forms of efficiency and various
forms of fairness but he must think of
them in the context of special cases and
humans are very bad at actually sifting
through all of the possible special
cases of which there are more than the
number of atoms in the universe we
developed this new framework which we
call future match where we take as input
to humans value judgments and then using
AI based simulation and past data we can
actually optimize the policy parameters
as to how do you best achieve those
goals so we're separating the means and
the ends the humans are talking about
ends and the AI is figuring out the
means and I think that this is a very
important separation for the future in
many different areas of AI that's almost
sent home our colleague right here at
Carnegie Mellon University and the
school of computer science now I'm very
pleased to introduce our first speaker
he's gonna set the stage for about 20
minutes and then we're gonna have a
little discussion the comfortable
armchairs in the middle our first
speaker is Sean dae-ho Shobha and I'm
happy to welcome him to the stage
what Shonda is an engineer at RAND
Corporation and he's a professor at the
party ran school his background is
perfect for this his background is in
machine learning optimization control
but he's also branched from machine
learning into health defense and
Technology Policy so from there he's
going to data privacy and accountability
so you notice I mentioned pretty much
all the key words as we look at the way
AI integrates into society before
joining Rand or Sunday was at USC and
indeed got his PhD there in electrical
engineering
and without further ado welcome ocean
day so today we're going to be talking
about equity of access and equity of
impact and how artificial intelligence
mediates transforms affects those two
things I will be suggesting that we look
to the Past look to antiquity to sort of
help us see what's going on in the
future I want us to focus on these two
individuals Plato and Socrates my
contention is that the interaction the
difference is in the way these two
people work kind of sort of pre figures
are complexities the complexity of
dealing with today when it comes to AI
and equity if there is a key takeaway
point from from this conversation I hope
it would be the idea of participatory
equity I will be making the contention
that that should be the foundation of
any successful infrastructure for
ethically aligned what fish or fair AI
now that I have given you the key point
we can all take naps basically back to
Plato so the mental image I have a Plato
is of this undoubted genius but he's
also this guy who's deeply deeply
scarred by one pivotal event in his life
and that's the state sanctioned
execution of his teacher and mentor of
Socrates Socrates Plato reacts to that
event by retreating from the marketplace
of ideas from the from the population
from the community and he sets up this
he sets up this archetype for the
solitary contemplative philosopher and
he he desires you to peers in which
basically the demos the people that he
that he kind of pulls back from sort of
always subject to some philosopher king
and that is the idea what a fair society
is and it does is without engaging with
the people at all he just designed this
from
now contrast this to how Socrates does
inquiry he engages deeply and very very
critically with the community he's
engaged he's around when he asked when
he has to answer the simple question
what is wisdom now he doesn't get his
answer he doesn't get a definite I'm
definitely to answer from that question
from an interaction but at least he can
claim some defense against the biases
that his personal perspective
necessarily brings to that conversation
think about how these two men might have
thought about the questions that lay
before us today
the idea of equity what is equity and
how do our giri's make decision-making
artifacts interact with equity Aristotle
makes an appearance in discussions of
equity also but we won't focus on him
today back in the day a few months ago I
was introduced as done as an engineer of
fairness that's a little bit of a
paradoxical title engineers have this
image of being objective precise
analysts while fairness is this very
contextual very socially defined very
fuzzy concept that slippery to define I
argue that any any discussion of
artificial intelligence and equity is
going to be doomed to this compress of
opposite qualities it used to be that
when we talked about AI equity people
sneer at us they'll say things like well
what is equity in the same way that
Pontius Pilate probably asked what is
truth and typical conversations about AI
policies they were focused on these
future looking scenarios this Terminator
scenarios these are existential crises
and I would argue that that that focus
that's a product of a privileged
perspective a perspective they cannot
imagine the problems of AI affecting us
today they have to look to the future to
see to imagine things that go wrong now
that is probably a lazy argument so I
offer a reconciliation so here we have
parking
along pushing that line of inquiry let
me offer a reconciliation by observing
that questions of AI equity and AI
safety existential safety concerns they
actually share common wheat for example
they are concerned with value alignment
by value alignment I mean how do we
design algorithms that that support
society defined norms they also share
the problem of explained ability in the
in the interest of X of procedural
transparency we would like to be able to
derive stable robust meaningful
explanations from the algorithmic
decision making artifacts but let's
focus on equity when you focus on equity
there are there are there are these
definitional problems there are these
issues these are perceived that picture
in the definition of equity and it's a
great thing that we now have examples
that in spite of the arbitrary in spite
of definition of problems they're able
to demonstrate examples of algorithms
violating socially defined equity norms
these examples have done as deep and and
huge service of kind of sort of
challenging that deep slumber of settle
opinion that algorithms are necessarily
fair and infallible in fact we have
researchers now saying that any any
technological design necessarily embed
ethical decisions necessarily embed
values either implicitly or explicitly
when we talk about AI equity with those
conversations turn on how those values
align with society defined expectations
of fairness the first is a street bump
example the second is a compensation
division and the third is insurance
price in the last two examples were sort
of where the result of ProPublica is
explorations let's try to examine how
bias is my seep into our supposedly
objective infallible algorithms we are
probably familiar with how a I systems
are designed this is really design phase
a programming
is a training phase and a testing phase
but right here in the design of an
algorithmic artifact to make a decision
we have situations where we have framing
artifacts framing effects when you
design a system to make decisions and
you focus any frame it as an
optimization on predictive accuracy it
shouldn't be surprising when you have
fairness fairness problems with that
with that design
besides the the actual framing effects
in the design you have inputs that are
used to design the systems these usually
consist of data and assumptions at least
in models that is to come machine
learning models you know all the AI
models they relied more on rules and
assumptions explicit rules and
assumptions but even in these inputs you
have this problem and I'm using terms
from behavioral economics to help us
maybe frame this better we have this
Pirlo of naive realism where the model
assumes that the data it give it's it's
able to see is a complete contextual
representation of the real world so you
can imagine a model trained on a subset
of the population assuming that the
general population to which to going to
be applied looks like that training set
that's a form of naive realism or you
can imagine an algorithm trying to make
inferences about people's networks based
on just social media links assuming that
social media links represent the full
state of connections in the real world
that's a form of naive realism we also
have this issue of anchoring biases
statistical models they tend to
basically anchor on examples they've
seen in the past this is an example of a
generalization error problem and so by
anchoring on those examples in the
future when it's presented with things
it's not familiar with you have these
anchors that can sort of help sometimes
they help sometimes they're not so good
the last part where biases can seep in
isn't the outcomes so we have this issue
we might call outcome bias or automation
bias where we assume that the process
the outcome of our decision-making
artifact characterized the quality of
the of the decision-making artifact it's
just like the the key example here might
be saying well a broken
clock is correct twice a day if you
observe it only have those two points of
the day you think it's it's working
perfectly but you're not thinking about
the process by which is getting those
decisions you're not questioning whether
that's correct or not so this is just a
framing I might suggest for how we might
think about how biases in equity CPM to
grade make decision-making like
artifacts let's try to be I'm going to
try to present two examples to case
studies where we can examine how an
algorithm might have to deal with equity
concerns the first is the use of
algorithms in criminal justice example
applications of the use of algorithms as
reflected in a compass report it is the
use of algorithms for setting bills and
for sentencing it used to be that
compass was mainly for setting bail
increasingly there was a feature creep
where it was increasingly used for
sentencing now the frame I'm going to
use to talk about this case to design
exam is something I'm hoping we can take
away from this conversation every time
you think about algorithms in
decision-making which you think about
the problem is trying to solve in this
case bills bill setting a sentencing but
we should also be explicit about the
guiding norms the equity norms that
decision making artifact is subject to
in the context of criminal justice I
would argue that we have at least two
norms the equal protection norm
guaranteed by the US Constitution at
least in the United States and you might
also argue for the due process norm
guaranteed by the Fifth Amendment rights
the second example the second case study
the second domain would be algorithms
not insurance insurance represents this
it solves this social social function of
safeguarding people from catastrophic
risk and so it's not surprising that
insurers might want to use algorithms to
help them make their make their
decisions more accurate more fair
example applications example problems
here are the problems of rate setting
and underwriting rate certain is just
really about setting the price of an
insurance premium
underwriting is kind of sort of gauging
the risk the risk tranches for people
who are supposed to be insured now what
would be the insurance the guiding norm
in the situation this is a bit more
complicated and I'd argue that the
actuarial
this body of the United States says well
your insurance prices should be actually
fair ie
the cost of an insurance premium should
reflect on the lying risk of the person
but then we have these issues when we
start asking for universal health care
mandate universal insurance mandate I
have to worry about affordability being
part of the norms here now in a market
setting that might be a problem these
are questions we'll have to tease out as
we as we think about equity going
forward let's try to use these case
studies to tease out more general ideas
well the very first idea or the very
first theme is that equity norms and
necessarily context-specific that's an
almost obvious statement but that
obvious statement kind of undermines our
expectation that maybe there is this
prescriptive mathematical definition of
equity that we just need to impose on
algorithms to make them fair that's
probably not going to happen and we can
actually add more to we can actually add
more context more complexity to this to
this issue of the existence of
prescriptive equity norms work by I hope
I'm pronouncing that name properly sure
- over and our crime berg Emily Nathan
they are addressing they are identifying
what we might call weak impossibility
theorems that if you have a set of a set
of mathematically defined equity norms
that you would hope your decision-making
artifact respect in this case group
calibration equality of negative force
positive or false negative rate equality
or false positive rate there is
something inherently incompatible in
trying to achieve all three equity norms
and conversations a few a few months a
few weeks ago at the fat ml conference
extended this to any collection of
equity mathematically defined equity
norms trying to satisfy more than three
and three or more is income is
impossible we can call that on a weak
impossibility theorem now you might hear
this and think well since I can have it
all
let me just have let me have my users
vote to decide which is and which ones
are important
but then we run into impossibility
theorem is the stronger impossibility
theorems by Kenneth arrow Bieber dance
after tweet saying essentially it's
impossible to reasonably aggregate
Collective normative preferences alright
so that's the second theme the third
team I'm trying to have been trying to
develop over the past year or so or to
thinking about this is this framing of
allocation problems distribution
problems as entitlement programs versus
market programs we can think about it as
a spectrum entitlement distribution
programs the distribution problems in
which there are clear equity norms
guiding the decision process the
distribution distributed decision
process normative clarity usually means
that there is some law some regulation
and everybody accepts that determines
how fair our decision is you can think
about the example of United States
criminal justice you have the public
good law enforcement that's being
distributed to the public under the
normative guidelines of equal protection
and due process but we also have what we
might think of as market programs market
distribution programs are just
distribution programs where equity norms
play little or no role and the
distributive action is determined
largely by the intersection of demand or
supply now let's try to figure out
questions that come up from this in the
entitlement programs you have the
question of are the norms necessarily
equitable and if they are not equitable
are there remedies for it social
movements like black lives matter and
civil rights movements they are
essentially challenges to the equity
norms they rule in equity norms at the
time and we have the same essentially
that legality is not really a question
of justice the question of power and we
switch over to the market session
you have this issue of there is a
trade-off between the accuracy the
efficiency of the market and the
imposition of equity norms if we try to
make a market fair accordance on the
equity norms you can often impose a
deadweight cost what is essentially dead
wood cost
the question becomes who gets to bear
that burden and how big is that burden
that sounds theoretical highfalutin in
concrete terms you can think about it in
terms of the mark the insurance market
in health insurance if you have
universal mandate who gets to bear the
cost of that increasing in risk just
because you have universal mandate less
controversially initially in auto
insurance market who gets to bear that
cost those are questions we have to
tackle with we have to grapple with if
we really care about equity in the
decision-making systems all right I feel
like I've been a bit negative about the
prospect of algorithmic equity let's try
to see if I can pull out more positive
vision from the rubble
we've I've been poking holes in the idea
that you can actually define press
creative equity enormous mathematically
and impose them on your algorithms and
even if such a thing existed you will
still need a buy-in of your subjects of
your users that is not easy to to to
maintain to receive in a dictatorial
technocracy so this suggests that maybe
we should be thinking more about
participate reversions participatory
models of AI equity basically these will
be models in which your users which
constantly
query your users for equity concerns
when we talk about diversity in the rank
this is the diversity point you knew it
was coming so whatever when we talk
about diversity in the ranks of
algorithmic designers we are not just
pleading special circumstances it's
precisely because by having more design
more diversity in the rank of designers
you're pulling in more social
perspectives to inform the design
process but even diversity diversify is
not enough because if you think about it
algorithms are always necessarily going
to act well generally going to affect
more people than are being represented
in the designer class
so what you're going to need is
something that allows for for more
participation from wider groups and we
can sharpen this point by observing that
equity challenges equity concerns
they're distributed form of knowledge
there is no single controlling group
that's ever going to be able to
coordinate the transmission and
accommodation of equity challenges so we
need more participation basically we
need more more most Socrates and fewer
Plato's designing from from isolation we
need people who are going to go out
there and do the messy work of engaging
with the subject and this is where I'm
reminded again of shoulder shoulders
work on the Allegheny County child
welfare system it's really good work
which is why I'm talking about it now
besides the participatory model we might
want to think about instead of
prescriptive norms we might want to
think about infrastructures for imposing
for enabling and designing equity into
algorithmic decision-making systems this
is kind of sort of the gdpr route
instead of trying to impose norm as you
impose it like you define an
infrastructure that enables good
behavior to to happen now you might want
to ask ourselves what are the key the
minimal key components of such an
infrastructure I want to argue for three
or three or four fluency we need more
fluency in the principles of equity so
the economist Peyton Jung put it this
way
equity principles these norms I've been
going on about and the mathematical
definitions of these norms they are
really just instruments they're not end
in themselves they're just imposed in an
algorithm they are really instrument by
which society kind of sort of
adjudicates equity problems distributive
problems especially when efficient in
market efficiency fails as a as a
criterion now if we are not fluent in
the language of equity principles
they're going to have problems properly
adjudicated and responding to equity
concerns
the second one under which I'll combine
it to transparency and dissent I think
primarily it's about dissent you need
any implementation any algorithmic
implementation to have basically settled
avenues for for enabling dissent for
collecting dissent from the users part
of that dissent procedure will probably
require transparency at all the norms
governing the area throughout the domain
and thirdly I think this is the part
that feels especially in privacy
conversations you need methods for
accountable redress you need to be able
to have institutions be able to make and
keep promises you need incentives to
allow that to happen usually at least
according to GDP GDP GDP are basically
says or the way to do that is by having
these steep fines and I'm inclined to
agree because we have a history of data
breaches that have that has not abated
in spite of the small fines we've been
having so far these are the ideas I have
out there I I will admit that my
conversation has been from a very
allocated distribution perspective I I
want to acknowledge Kate Crawford
perspective that besides allocated
problems you have representational harms
that come from using algorithms in
society windows allocate renders when
algorithms that have that will present
the proper distribution and society this
disparate distributions of society are
now responsible for shaping our
preferences what does that mean long
term that's all I have for you
[Applause]
thank you
now we get to relax and talk take any
chair as long just one in the middle -
that's like a fair allocation problem
that's right so fascinating talk we have
a few questions we're gonna ask
everybody but I have to drill into what
you said first okay first of all you
know when you talked about weak and
strong impossibility there was a point
there that I think it's important to
reiterate for the audience so I want to
ask you to build out a little bit
because this idea that mathematically
achieving a computational way of
including the norms of equity such that
the computer system itself the robot the
AI system can execute and guarantee that
mm-hmm what I heard you say is that
that's essentially impossible yeah I
mean I mean we can all we can all talk
about okay we want equal we can oh wait
we can make arguments for certain equity
principles to be enforced in algorithms
but at some point a group is going to
argue and see actually the outcome on
our end is is violate what we think is
fair you're going to have to accommodate
that non theoretical that very practical
messy equity concern and that probably
means moving away from mathematically
precise definitions of equity and trying
to kind of engage with them I I think
the judgment hand he put it this way he
said equity concerns
well equity is really just about the the
the uncomfortable accommodation of
conflict to the society trying to do
that in a precise mathematical way might
not be a robust solution long term this
reminds me of talking to urban designers
who say there's this thing called the
wicked problem you can't optimize
because this is a social challenge
exactly and this also reminds me of the
defense argument this says we'll make
the perfect robot soldier argument
against which is no actually even war is
social we don't optimize it
quantitatively yep yep well so this is
interesting if it's the case that we
can't actually hope for an AI system
that will make the world equitable by
the very nature of how its programmed
then you talked about participatory
equity which I love except when I look
at this
like Facebook er AdWords on Google what
I see is participatory systems and what
I see in those systems is since no
system is equitably perfect so to speak
people find a way to hack them yep and
then use their own asymmetric levers of
power there to hack the very
participatory system you created to do
things like throw say I don't know an
election so that's not funny but ability
so I would argue that maybe the the the
issue is probably mechanism design
learning to to put in incentives and in
platforms that allow that allow for this
type of for correcting for these types
of evolutionary behaviors over time
trying to a priority design a perfect
system that's like you're saying it's
not going to happen so it's about insane
structural incentives creating an
infrastructure for for for modifying
them over time so then here's my fear I
totally get that we're gonna make
systems we'll make them as as good as we
can
people will misuse them they're only bad
actors and we're going to respond we're
gonna have a rapid reaction to that but
here's my concern the AI systems we're
talking about are inherently
accumulating and concentrating power and
knowledge which means the bad actors
ability to negatively influence reality
it's big and only bigger next year and
the year after here so it seems to me by
the time we catch them the crimes get
worse before we do the redress or the
things so don't we have this weird
runaway problem yes is it so my so I
this these are problems I think about
every day and I talk about with my with
fellow researchers at Rand and one of my
fellow research because I dislike the
solution right I don't see a way around
it one of my fellow researchers rant
Walsman he argues that the way to
address this is to have adversarial
reaction so the first person the bad
actors do something like flooding for
the net with with Reznick fake news and
the solution is for the good actors to
flood the net with resonant true-true
News and the idea is how to is basically
this back and forth between between
actors I see that as a runaway situation
yeah but thinking of solutions is hard
so that's really scares me that's a good
way to start the conference because
we're clearly into the conference so let
me jump on my extreme level of fear now
that I have to the three questions we're
hoping to ask everybody because this
gives us a neat thread to push
throughout the whole conference I think
you answered one of them already but I'm
getting ahead of myself
the first question I really want to
narrow your view and unfortunately cause
you to prognosticate a little bit into
the future I want to look at the next
ten years hmm and I want to ask the
question what is the thing you're most
excited about visa Vai and equity what
is it what is something you can imagine
that that's actually doable the next ten
years where AI can actually help with
questions of equity was a good one we
didn't share these with the speakers
ahead of time so I think we already seen
this happening maybe ten years is too
far out the issue of credit allocation
credit scoring for thin file for thin
flour subjects people who don't have
large records in large formal records in
the economic sectors so this would be
like people in developing countries poor
people the ability to use artificial
intelligence to I tried to use the term
algorithm intelligence as often as I can
the ability to use machine learning
methods to learn about credit score
about credit worthiness from all the
sources of data seems to me extremely
powerful well if if properly applied and
properly supervised because you can also
use the type of scoring mechanism for
things like the China the Chinese
approach of social scoring but just
enabling better credit to people in
poorer situations he's a huge
transformative fit I think and I love
that answer because it also brings into
the play the whole question of
developing world and ways in which
developing world may access what we're
talking about so the second question is
the exact opposite again limiting
ourselves to ten years or so what is it
that most
keeps you up at night in terms of equity
and AI mmm mine don't sleep regularly so
you know I tend to avoid projects
involve in heart defense because it
makes me really anxious and the question
of deterrence in a world in which we
have a I enabled weapons makes me
worried and worse than that it's not
just the existence of the weapons that
makes me worried its take is the
differences in the culture the cultures
deploying those weapons if you think
about the Chinese the Chinese our
approach to defense in the American
approach to defense you have basically
China seeming to be more trusting of
just wholesale fully automated weapons
and you have United States doctrine say
something to the effect that will always
have humans in the loop that that that
makes sense from that seems comfortable
comforting from a unilateral perspective
but imagine a situation in which a
country has human loop for all the
autonomous systems and the other country
just doesn't care that seems to have
deterrent implications that are
difficult to think about so lack of
parity may actually force a good actor
to become less good yep indeed last
question for you is an interesting
future in question that's kind of
navel-gazing about this conference so
imagine we're here 15 years from now
having this conference mmm how will it
look or feel different because of AI I
assume most people would not actually be
here would have bots in telepresence
always be talking to a set of screens
here yeah III like this idea and maybe I
mean I'm trying to imagine how that
would apply in a conference setting I
like this idea of our clock on traumas
extended mind I feel like most of us
will be more invested in the tools that
enable us to engage with the world and
so maybe we'll have augmented brains of
some sort that make us faster thinkers I
always think about how to think faster
how to think more creatively and I
imagine that artificial intelligence
will probably enabled
the future so cognitive orthotics for us
all maybe yeah excellent well thank you
so much for joining us wonderful speech
we're gonna be heading now to a panel
discussion that lets us actually relax
and hear more on the issue of equity
with a wonderful panel of guests but can
I bring up the slide
Oh slides so we can let folks know how
they're gonna be using slide oh if I'm
even saying its name correctly slider is
a technology that's going to allow you
to ask questions our journalist who is
the moderator for this panel will see
your questions on her screen and so she
can pick and choose from amongst the
common features of the questions to
bring your comments and questions into
the conversation she's having with the
panel so what you're seeing is the
website for slide oh you can go to that
with any mobile device once you get
there you simply enter that hashtag and
when you do so then all the questions
you ask will show up on the handy-dandy
tablet that we're providing to our
moderator so without further ado I'll be
introducing the moderator who in turn
will introduce the panel as a whole I'm
really pleased to introduce my precious
singer because I have been reading
natashia singers articles for years
she's a technology reporter for the New
York Times and she covers health
technology education technology and
consumer privacy she's reporting on how
tech companies are developing digital
health tools and the implications
dead-house for healthcare industry and
for privacy for medical practice and for
consumers and I believe she's a teacher
too so she's one of us fellow professors
she has taught even a high school course
on technology innovation ethics at the
school of the New York Times pre-college
program the New York Times runs so thank
you for joining us Natasha thank you for
having me
so I'm just gonna briefly announce the
panelists and then I'm gonna invite them
to come up and talk for a minute about
their work and how it relates to AI and
I'm delighted that we have kind of such
a range of views so first is Michael
scorpion who is the co-founder of
community forge which is a nonprofit
that has bought a former school and is
revamping it into a kind of incredible
multi-use community center and we have
Rajesh ratha who is the chief innovation
officer of the University of Pittsburgh
Medical Center and we have Alexandra
Childers OVA who is an assistant
professor of statistics and public
policy here at CMU so why don't you guys
come up and then Moll
[Applause]
so Alex do you want to start just one
minute about each of yourselves and then
we'll get started with hashing out these
big questions introduce lesson starting
first I think everyone can hear me in
the room is that correct great closer to
the mic excellent
so I'm Alex shoulder shava as Natasha
said I'm an assistant professor here at
Carnegie Mellon University and I'm a
statistician by training most of my work
these days concerns the use of AI or
really risk assessment tools in the
context of government operations
specifically I look at how these tools
are being used in high-stakes
applications such as criminal justice
and human services as a previous speaker
mentioned I've done some work motivated
by some of the public analyses and one
of the things that I try to challenge as
a statistician is this adage that if you
have bias in you have bias out which has
come out of this idea of garbage in
garbage out and the way I think that we
can challenge this is that to the extent
that we really understand how is it that
the data that we're using as the basis
for our systems how did that become
biased we can make some Corrections and
really move well well extract the
information that we need and move
towards more equitable solutions hi
everyone my name is Russ Resta I'm
actually a radiologist by background so
when you hear all the hype around run
for the hills
AI is coming the machines are after us
and the radiologists are the first to be
eliminated Here I am
so as the radiologist by background I
have some views on AI but what I do at
UPMC really is i'm the chief innovation
officer UPMC us some of you or many of
you might know is a large healthcare
organization we're a payer and a
provider organization and when it comes
to the topic of ethics and AI and equity
we really believe that it's important
for us to see healthcare as something
that is very human so my role at UPMC
to take all of the data that we have
around these human beings all of the
data that we have around the medicine
and the science of really pushing health
and healthcare to the next level and
algorithm eyes these to innovate around
these to think outside the box and
really question the status quo right so
I in addition to being the chief
innovation officer UPMC I'm also really
privileged to be part of you PMC
enterprises which is our innovation and
entrepreneurship arm and working with
the best and brightest minds here in the
Pittsburgh area especially here at CMU
and the University of Pittsburgh we're
really pushing the boundaries of how we
can look at data to reinvent the future
of healthcare reinvent the future of
what health will look like not just 10
years into the future but further down
line at the downstream as well so really
excited about the conversation that
we're having today because it's not
about the hype it's about the reality of
what it means to take these algorithms
and make a difference in the lives of
these human beings that were trying to
impact day in and day out thank you hi
and I'm Michael Skupin so my background
is actually in this tough translation
problem I think about which our session
speaker talked about which is how do we
actually articulate our social norms in
terms of technical decisions and
technical processes that we're trying to
champion so a lot of what I've done is
worked with students so on pedagogical
practices for engineers who are in
training but also on professionals who
are designing technical system
specifically machine learning systems
and choosing what data mining operation
they're going to have or what training
procedure they're going to use and
actually trying to get them to project a
future a little bit about well what does
this small technical decision I'm making
here of choosing this sorting algorithm
on this interface or potential using
this data set to try to train on this
against this objective how do I get
people to actually think a little bit
about what's going to be the social
impact of this choice and what are some
of my options and how do they relate to
that social impact and so that is
actually a very difficult translation
problem and that's what I spent most of
my active
make time viewing but now I'm the
director of a community center which is
in Wilkinsburg Pennsylvania which is a
neighbouring borough right here in
Pittsburgh and so what we're trying to
do there is actually also a little bit
to our session speaker also he was
talking about is be deeply engaged in a
community setting as a group our leaders
range from across the board at the
community center from technologists like
myself and a few others but also to
educators and community servants who are
already working in the region and our
goal is to be deeply connected with that
community and be sure that we're
creating an inner community space where
people can learn from each other and
work with one another and as our session
speakers said actually learn from folks
who understand problems on the ground
better than folks who are in the
research lab or who are actually working
on these problems in an academic setting
and be able to actually help people
articulate their problems to us so that
we can then actually correctly have the
right head on our shoulders around what
we're trying to do rather than
potentially project what we think should
be happening and so our community center
is a very very I would say like scrappy
effort to to try to make sure that that
is happening and we do things such as
education services getting kids into
pathways around technology who might not
otherwise have those opportunities but
also as a civics and community service
project to really just make sure that
those conversations are happening and
that there's a space for them and so
that's a lot what the community center
about which is a you know output of some
of the things I think about an academic
setting so I was really excited to come
and moderate this panel because as a
journalist the question of access and
impact of technology or things I deal
with every day but also as a journalist
right my training is to be skeptical and
question assumptions so when I was
invited to moderate this the first thing
I did was have this knee-jerk reaction
and call up and say you know why are we
focusing on equity of access and equity
of impact because that really makes an
assumption that a AI is an inevitable
and B it's a known good that the good
outweighs the horn and we don't know
that yet
and then I said you know also I think
it's really important to focus on biased
datasets and bias algorithms and
disparate impact but this obsession we
have with computational fairness seems
to distract also from some of the big
problems and so I called my panelists
and discovered that you know everybody
also is a bit of an insurrectionist so
we're gonna talk about some of the
expected questions but we're also going
to talk about some of the fundamental
questions and so you know the first
question is just an establishing
question Alex maybe you want to start
question is when we talk about AI and we
talk about equity what is it we're
actually talking about I think in many
ways we're talking about the very same
things that we're referring to and we
speak about equity of any process so in
my experience a lot of the concerns that
we have in let's say criminal justice is
a risk of just perpetuating the very
same disparities that the system already
absorbedly suffers from so I think
what's really important to keep in mind
when we think about these equity issues
is compared to what baseline that
there's certainly a risk that as we
switch to more algorithmic or at least
algorithmically supported decision
systems that we could exacerbate those
same problems or we could address them
and I think that's really at the core of
equity that this is not a new problem
that AI has brought about it's something
old that we're now trying to address
perhaps with some new tools yeah so I
think when we're talking about equity as
as Alexandra said we're often thinking
about inequities that already exist and
then could be compounded by AI solutions
and the approaches that we take so so
I'm very interested in and I'm when I
think about equity and I hear about it I
do have this kind of two sides of the
coin of is the AI system already out
there
did we make something and then is it
actually creating something an inequity
that we maybe already understand and
knowbut maybe it's already being
produced in another way and now we're
actually replicating it or accelerating
it or maybe we're
amazing it but we are missing some edge
cases still but then there's also the
side of how is inequity just exacerbated
by the push of this industry thinking
about how where is investment coming
from who are the people who get the
chance to decide what the objectives are
as many of you probably know when you're
designing an AI system it's always
towards an objective towards a task that
you're trying to develop a machine
learning algorithm for and who gets to
decide what is the relevant approach to
that so when you think about say a
recidivism score is there also an
objective or we say does this prisoner
have the social support network to go
out and actually get a job or to
potentially go on a pathway out of you
know involved in involvement in crime
and is there a way to use AI to predict
whether this person's social system is
just not gonna be you know supportive
enough to be able to get them back on
their feet is that an alternative look
at a recidivism score what a different
person when thinking about that problem
see it that way and so yeah so that's
what I'm kind of thinking about is where
does it come from when we first start
thinking about AI and then also thinking
well now we have any AI solution is is
it being equitable in practice and how
do you think about it in terms of equity
and health care yeah so it's really
interesting when you think about health
care as I mentioned earlier there's
nothing really more humane or human than
this pursuit of excellence in providing
best quality care that you can to fellow
human beings now when you talk about
equity in health care it really is about
making sure that you have access to care
and making sure that you're fair about
who has access and what level or what
quality of access these human beings
have to those care processes so when you
really think about the three-legged
stool of health care the three point
five trillion dollar industry that's
health care today it's cost quality and
access right and you know some would add
a fourth stool there around experience
but when you think about cost quality
and access cost continues to accelerate
it continues to go up
quality is somewhat still questionable
in terms of
what it is that we're really going for
around creating those the outcomes that
we desire around the health processes
that we're putting in place and then
access to care I think is getting better
but having said that the topic that
we're talking about today i I think
potentially has the potential to level
the playing field in ways that we've
just not been able to do in healthcare
it has the potential for example in
being able to bring to the common man
algorithms that perhaps the richest and
those that had that were privileged only
had in example treating cancer right
specific types of protocols that we were
able to really push forward in only
perhaps you know that the wealthiest of
nations or the wealthiest of areas and
now we're able to really reproduce these
at scale we're able to look at data at
scales that would just not been able to
do before and be able to then impart
these in in larger populations of
patients as we absolutely need to be
doing so like cancer genomics cancer
genomics is one specific area right
where we have petabytes worth of data
that we have access to where the notion
of machine learning and artificial
intelligence becomes actually an enabler
of better care so the notion here yes is
of taking these algorithms and in many
ways trying to democratize the process
of providing excellent care for not as
populations of patients that in this
case may have a certain type of a tumor
but also around the notion of precision
medicine which is really looking at not
just the N of many but the N of one
right so one individual that may have
specific types of bio receptors certain
types of perhaps even preferences in
terms of how he or she may want to be
treated
zip code that that person that patient
may be living in and other types of
social determinants
factors that might influence his or her
behaviors or specific outcomes so really
trying to personalize the care to that
nf1 I think is the new reality of what
we might be able to put in place so it's
interesting cuz you both mentioned power
asymmetries Mike in the fact that if you
have AI in the hands of a few you're
gonna have a few powerful entities
choosing what the problems are to solve
and how to solve them and you've
mentioned a i's possible way of
democratizing access to higher-end
healthcare or more innovative healthcare
but I want to go back to the power
question because it's a foundational
moment and we see that a handful of
really big players the googles and the
Facebook's and the ubers have a
concentration of power knowledge and
financial gain and what do we do about
that in the context of AI and also some
of those companies have huge databases
of consumer data right but those
consumers aren't being compensated for
their data yet it's going to cause
financial gain so how do we do deal with
like equity of distribution of benefits
Alex do you wanna start I think in many
ways there's strong parallels to the way
we think about experimentation in
medical contexts or in research contexts
if you think about the steps that an
academic researcher has to go through in
order to collect specific data on human
subjects or to perform particular
experiments that affect human subjects
these are governed by internal review
boards and codes of ethics and research
standards that have evolved over decades
and with good reason because without
them there were considerable human
rights abuses taking place as we were
pursuing knowledge for in general the
greater good in the corporate context I
think and I mean they're not the first
person to propose this there has been a
push to consider what does human
subjects research actually look like in
that context so where are the human
subjects and experimentation and why is
this a problem outside of
the research community well if you think
about what's going on in the large
technology companies they run millionths
of a beat us running experiments on us
every day
many of them are benign but some of them
actually carry a risk of harm and as
soon as whatever it is that you're
trying to toggle carries a risk of harm
to individuals then there is a question
of who are you experimenting on have
they provided meaningful informed
consent and how do we even ensure that
we can collect such a thing in the
context of let's say the terms of use
that we sign and I think we need to
rethink kind of the liberties that
corporations can take or private
entities can take and experimenting on
their users because there is potentially
a real risk of harm in some of these
instances depending on precisely what it
is they're doing so one example that
comes up is for instance rideshare
companies experiment on routes and whose
routes are going to be experimented on
if I'm moving around the main body of
Manhattan no one's gonna experiment on
me if I'm in some of the lower
socioeconomic neighborhoods certainly
there would be considerable
experimentation and that may lead to
measurable harm and if you think about
it sure I sign or I click agree on a
term of use but when we go into a
doctor's office whatever forms we saw
and it doesn't just allow the doctor to
experiment on us however it is that they
want to improve their medical service so
at any juncture where there's a
meaningful risk of harm I think we need
to reassess this issue of informed
consent and actually that involves
thinking a little bit ahead as to what
are the potential harms that might
result so that leads me to my fellow
question because I've covered this a
little bit and we're seeing as I'm sure
you all know that companies are making
inferences about our health from the way
we use technology and I've been struck
by the differences and approaches
between Microsoft and Facebook so a few
years ago Microsoft did this study on
depression on Twitter and they got 171
people to volunteer and give Microsoft
one-time acts
to their Twitter feed and so Microsoft
developed algorithms that went back and
looked over time you know they knew when
the onset of depression was and what
were the tweets like before and after
and looking at the number of words in
the tweets the time of the tweets the
kind of words used in the tweets and
they discovered that you know when they
tested the algorithm on the group they
developed it on it was 70% accurate now
I know that there were 171 volunteers
and it was 70% accurate because
Microsoft published this but Facebook
recently deployed this suicide detection
algorithm and it is scanning every
single post every single day on Facebook
and also every video without really
telling anybody and when I call to say
hey you know who did you consult and are
you gonna publish the data and you know
do you have kind of informed consent and
kind of consumers opt-out and how do you
measure harm there really weren't any
answers and so I want to ask you rather
like what do we do about that
if you throw I'd this experiment at UPMC
you would need an internal review board
so so if it's even a specific health
thing that tech companies are looking
for what should we do so I think
especially in this time and in this age
where we have you know set of dire needs
to really push technologies like AI
forward and you know like I said earlier
really try to bring to scale the
capabilities that we've we've been
really working on in the pursuit of say
excellence in health care which is my
space I think the need the impetus for
us to double down perhaps on ethics is
all the more important it is such a
slippery slope it can be a very very
slippery slope for us not to do that for
us to say hey but you know it's
information that's out there and we're
trying to do this and the greater good
of humanity anyway yes we are but at the
same time we're talking about human
beings when it comes to human subjects
there are specific IRB type protocols as
Alex Minh
that are there for a reason right so
there's a right way to go about doing
this and a wrong way to go about doing
this and we believe that that's part of
the reason why UPMC and UPMC enterprises
exists right so we're working with you
know large companies like Microsoft for
example and taking large troves of data
we have three point
sorry 227 petabytes worth of data at
UPMC its doubling every 18 months it
continues to increase exponentially but
we're working with machine learning
experts in AI experts and companies like
Microsoft and entrepreneurs and startups
but with a ethical pursuit taking into
account all of the rules and regulations
that IR bees have right so we're not
trying to shortchange those we're
working within the constraints but we're
doing this at scale leveraging these
technologies and capabilities so you
know I think it's time for us to double
down on these capabilities and making
sure that we're able to do this in the
most ethical manner possible and Mike
who do we think should regulate this
when we talk about equity of access and
equity of impact is it up to researchers
to be accountable for their own
innovations should the government come
in and regulate or legislate AI and make
sure it's equitable and then we have the
problem with you know there's a minority
of politicians who actually understand
how AI works so are they the right
audience yeah I mean I think it's gonna
have to be a mixed bag to say that
there's some kind of you know simple one
unilateral way in which we can kind of
ensure that this trust and
accountability is instilled in the
system I think that would be crazy so
it's gonna have to come in part from I
do think some amount of legislation or
regulation because even talking about
the things that Ross is talking about
and some of the exciting things you
think about well if we think that the
landscape of a certain industry say the
healthcare industry already has
inequities in it so the soil for the
seed to be planted in is already maybe
not actually the most fertile for
equality you probably are going to need
some kind of regulatory mechanism to
make sure the development of these of
these technologies is fair and that
might be pushing on antitrust law and
actually saying that what we cannot have
constant mergers and acquisitions so
that a few companies who can kind of
lobby for a position that's really
really good for them to deploy these
technologies rapidly without IRB or
without really good informed consent we
might need a way to prevent that at the
level of business but then we might also
have to say that okay there's gonna be
minimum standards for what data use or
data practices come with an informed
consent mechanism because as as
Alexander is talking about an IRB you're
you're actually agreeing to a very
specific study which you understand the
purpose of whenever I agree to a Terms
of Service on Facebook I broadly agree
to marketing or something product
development and to my partners using
this data and I do think that that is
gonna take then business leaders who say
okay actually enough with these you know
broad blanket provisions and they're
gonna have to have some potential
pressure from maybe somebody on the
litigation side or regulators saying
that hey if things don't clean up we're
actually going to have to change the way
that consent works and then maybe they
should say well we have to be more
specific named who our partners are or
named what exact things were actually
going to do with your data so people
have a way to to meaningfully choose
because right now I wouldn't I would say
that there's a consent procedure but the
informed parts been slashed for the most
part but then there's also
responsibility I think on on us as a
public which maybe is an educational
responsibility to become literate and
data literate and understanding things
that are really complicated right now
and I don't want to put too much of an
onus on people that you have to go out
and start reading up on machine learning
books but I do think people developing a
consciousness that when you put a photo
out there that there might actually be a
way to make an inference about medical
information from a photo I think a lot
of people don't even really know that or
can't connect those dots and so I do
think that's where I think academia and
educators probably have a responsibility
to their public to making sure as we're
developing these new techniques are we
actually doing outreach that helps
people understand the capabilities of
what their society around
is becoming and so and so and I think of
course the the last pieces with
academics and both Rossi and Alex are
great examples of this but academics who
also continually to challenge those
questions as they're doing the research
and put into place early on a priori to
offering up a paper of a new technique
also putting in here's the questions you
should interrogate of this technique
before it's commercialized before it's
done at scale and having those questions
up front so that somebody doesn't have
an excuse later to go back and say well
oh I had no idea should ask that
question which I think a lot is what
happens now people go wrap it forward
and then once the question arises here
becomes obvious it's like oh man I
should and I should have known or
something but we could potentially
preempt that a bit by making that part
of the research process so we talked
about all the possible things that could
go wrong and Alex I was hoping you would
talk about you know how do we measure
fairness and what examples do we have of
algorithms that are actually improving
impact and and can you talk a little
about your work with the Allegheny
children's welfare system sure so this
really is a place where I think we have
cause for optimism because in many
instances as I mentioned in my opening
remarks the baseline that we're
comparing to is very uninspiring and
this actually relates to what a lot of
people think of as a fundamental problem
in training fair algorithms which is the
bias and the original data but what does
that refer to it may refer to for
instance in the child welfare context
that were systematically screening and
for investigation families from
communities of color at higher rates
than white families and if you don't
look at the data if you never collect it
you'll never realize that this is an
issue with your existing process so in
part realizing that the data we might
want to use for some kind of downstream
purposes bias is suggesting to us that
there may be inequities in our existing
process that we might want to address
and correct for quantifying fairness is
extremely difficult and
the session speaker pointed out we do
have impossibility results that say that
you may have certain quantifiable
desiderata that you want to satisfy and
you just can't have it all fundamentally
but at the same time what we can do is
we can look at the system we can collect
data on the process we can see how well
it's currently performing and we can
think about what are the metrics that
matter most to us so maybe it's really
making sure that to the extent that we
can assess need or we can assess a kind
of dessert that the resources which are
inherently limited are being devoted to
individuals who are highest need or
highest risk and this is fundamentally
the primary question a lot of the
government uses of AI systems we want to
make use of data to identify families
that would benefit most from services or
most needy we want to identify criminal
defendants in the bail context who are
currently likely being detained on
account of being unable to pay bond and
replace that monetary bond system as
it's already been replaced in many other
countries with something else and
honestly anything else and this is where
for instance risk assessment presents a
nice balance satisfying some of these
safety concerns on the part of
prosecutors and judges while also
meeting this progressive reform goal at
least to some extent on the part of
defenders and the individuals who are
being detained by these systems so if
you look at some of the early results
from New Jersey who recently replaced
their monetary bond system with risk
assessment this evolved a lot more
process reform than simply putting in a
risk assessment score and saying go
everything's fixed but at the same time
this is something where we're seeing
we're replacing a root cause of
tremendous amount of new Finnick wa t
which is the monetary bond system with
something else so I have one more
question and then we're gonna open that
up for audience questions and so my
question is
the European Union is about to put in
this new data protection law the general
data protection regulation and one of
the stipulations is that citizens have
the right to not to be subject to
algorithmic processing if it will
significantly impact them and they also
have the right to explanation about what
criteria the algorithm used to make a
decision about them and I'm interested
in what you think about that and what
you think the impact of that's gonna be
and whether you think we should have
that in the United States so I think any
movement that really looks at the rights
of human beings and in the case of
health care the rights of patients and
consumers is a good good movement it's
good to ask questions right it'll be
interesting to see how it plays out in
in the European Union to be very honest
you know perhaps we have the luxury of
standing back and really looking at
what's worked and what's not worked
maybe taking some of the best aspects of
that maybe modifying it for the United
States the notion in healthcare in
general you know those reference earlier
this earlier speaker mentioned
participatory and and in and in making
the process more participatory I think
that's a good notion in healthcare in
particular healthcare traditionally has
been very paternalistic right you go to
a doctor's office and you expect for
care to be provided to you there's
almost a god complex of sorts between
the physician and the patient and also
between the patient and the physician it
goes both ways and it's changing right
now
you know consumers they go out and see
doctor Google before they go see dr.
Shrestha or my peers and that's a good
thing right we're more connected we're
more leaning in more more curious we're
more participatory than we've ever been
before
and that's that I think a good thing I
think what we can do however is we can
take the power of these algorithms to
further inform us because the notion of
equity is not just one of providing
access it's also one of empowering
consumers with tools incapable
to make better and more informed
decisions about themselves and their
loved ones and that's really the pursuit
that we're pushing forward with in terms
of innovation in healthcare so overall
it's a good thing you know we'll watch
and see what the Europeans do but to
question this to make sure that we're
able to you know speak to the specific
rights of the individuals it's it's it's
a good thing I'm fascinated by this
because I'm interested whether
individual Europeans are gonna challenge
you know algorithmic voter profiling and
advertising for example yeah I think
that that's the right to the explanation
explanation is one of those interesting
parts because right now you know say in
credit reporting we actually do have
auditing procedures that you have to go
through to show that you're doing fair
credit reporting and similarly with like
investment transactions through the SCC
although I've heard a lot of bad things
about those audits I do believe it's
good that the audits are in place and
yet there's no real audits for how we
train AI systems or anything and I think
the right to an explanation is going to
be good insofar as I'm not sure how much
teeth that's gonna end up having we'll
see but I do think it will at least get
people starting to figure out well how
do we even generate an explanation
what does useful audit actually look
like what information should be in place
for a court or for a judge to be able to
actually think meaningfully about what
happened but the piece that I'm most
interested in actually is actually the
data Portability piece of this and
that's because right now obviously once
you grow a huge user base even if you
find out that the company who has that
user base isn't really doing the best
things they have all the data and the
data is the power in the case of AI and
I think data Portability is a very
interesting part of this of whether
really it's going to come down that
people have to allow you to export and
move your data over into other services
because this would allow actually a real
competitive force potentially to take
place when Facebook suddenly does
something that people aren't so happy
about if Facebook is forced through the
gdpr to actually have a way to export
their data into a new social media
platform suddenly you could have smaller
groups show up and say well we're gonna
make a social media platform that's just
for Pittsburgh
oh and we can bring all your photo and
all your like history and all your
friend and everything you want over into
our platform like that so just to chime
in here um they've set up a system where
you can export your photos and your
posts right um and also you know your
logins and various other things but
under gdpr they're gonna also have to
give you if you ask your algorithmic
scores and any inferences they've made
about you and so far I haven't seen that
being portable so we're gonna have a
lightning round where I ask a few
questions and you can like take 30
seconds to answer so one of the
questions is is there a sense that we
might seriously need equity of being
able to avoid a in certain circumstances
so are there any circumstances in which
we should prohibit the use of AI or
where we don't want to develop a life
for that purpose I might steal Michaels
response here because we were just
talking about this question earlier but
my view is that there are certain times
when it's difficult to put all of our
values into a single objective that the
ASIS the AI system would then optimize
for and so to the extent that we need
additional controls over and above the
specific objective that the AI is
optimizing I think that's a place where
we should either not rely on it at all
if no part of our objective can be
formalized in this way or rely on it
with human guidance if there are certain
aspects that still require human control
questions for you it says if a is judged
as a tool rather than an experimental
treatment an IRB is not relevant
so what internal policy should
healthcare providers have in place I
think the specific guideline that we
should have in place is one of our moral
objectives right so why is it that we're
doing what it is that we're doing and
when you when you think about it in the
context of what I just mentioned there
then it becomes clearer for us because
what we're talking about here is to
really push not artificial intelligence
and these algorithms that you know
would look at all of the data elements
and say alright you know here's what
must be done for this human subject but
the specifics of what's in the best
interests of this human being that's at
the other end so I say this because when
we look at artificial intelligence I
look at artificial intelligence as less
about pushing the artificial mess of
care forward but really augmenting the
care process to Alex's earlier point in
one of the things that we need to be
doing is to making sure to be to be sure
that we're accounting for all of the the
human aspect of what it is that we're
doing so in providing health care so for
example in end-of-life decisions right
there are specific decisions that we can
algorithm eyes you know best practices
clinical protocols evidence-based
guidelines and we can Al Gore demise
these two to no end but there are also
specific preferences patients
preferences religious constraints that
that are in place and other things that
we absolutely have to look at it from a
very human perspective so there's things
that you know the IRB protocols will
obviously you know help you navigate
better at the same time we really need
to look at this with the lens of why it
is that we're pushing these algorithms
forward and what it is that we're we're
actually desiring in terms of the moral
objectives so two more questions when
Alex this is for you what are the
techniques used to remove biasness from
AI systems knowledge of how the bias got
there in the first place so it's
oftentimes extremely easy to write down
the mathematical correction formula and
it's extremely difficult to estimate all
the terms involved so without getting
too technical there is no
one-size-fits-all solution you really
need to understand what is the mechanism
by which that bias got into there and
that's in part why this area of kind of
ethics and algorithms is so
interdisciplinary that we have a
tremendous amount of literature from the
humanities and Social Sciences to rely
on and figuring out the how did it get
there on our way to correction
and here's another question how will we
create safeguards against possible AI
misbehavior and a totally a I run
society will will be able to pull the
plug so I just want to add something to
that because Mike and I were talking
about if we play the idea of autonomous
cars out to you know the end solution we
have nobody owning a car everybody
having a nap to call a driverless car
and the cars all owned by Google Google
and uber and a few other companies and
so what do we do if you're in China and
you use your app to call a driverless
car and it won't take you to a protest
you know what do we do like are we gonna
change the sharing economy to the
renting economy should driverless cars
be a kind of public utility now so sort
of that's my add to that question yeah I
mean I think that it's this is a huge
worry as the privatization of all of
this and and what it the consequences of
that are and I think we have to be
serious about making sure things that
are public goods or that are going to be
at scale affecting many many people of a
citizenry we have to have public options
that are have some oversight and that
have some transparency and some
back-and-forth of being able to have
effective dissidents against it and I
our speaker brought this up if we have
to have a way to have redress and have
to have a way to have a voice and say
this isn't actually working and right
now in the context of private companies
you don't really have that so I do think
that making sure we we deploy systems
with that in mind having public
officials who when they think about
what's the future of transportation
don't just say oh I can't wait for
Amazon and nuber to fix our
transportation system but that are also
kind of thinking hey I probably should
be thinking about how to expand our
public bus system at the same time so
that there's still options out there we
don't end up going to this like
asymptote of only uber or only Google
well thank you everybody thank you
audience
[Applause]
well thanks again to the wonderful panel
that was an excellent way to start this
program what I really enjoy is that
we're going deep and not at all being
superficial in the in the way we treat
these subject areas and that's fantastic
now one quick interlude and then you
will get to your copy break the
interlude is to first of all introduce
the K&L gates presidential fellowship
program one of the wonderful things that
Colonel gates did is they did not create
one giant pot of money and say do good
they actually created multiple specific
sub endowments that allow us to do many
things well and one of those is a
special pot of money for four fellows
those are graduate students we're doing
outstanding research in the area of
ethics and computational technology
there's a group that's selecting those
four fellows every year and those
fellows in turn provided the financial
support to allow those students to do
that work for that year so we're gonna
be meeting those four fellows one at a
time across today and tomorrow and so
I'm very pleased to introduce you to the
first one except that I'm introducing
you to the one who is not here in person
because she's on a trip so you're gonna
have a video introduction to her so let
me first tell you a little bit about her
and then we'll watch her video
the Karen legates Presidential Inaugural
Fellow in this program is Veronica
Mariota and Veronica completed a
bachelor's degree in economics and a
master's degree in science and economics
and business law at the University of
Rome at Toro variegata
she then earned a master's degree in
economics and mathematical economics at
Tilburg University School of Economics
and management now her focus area is
fantastic for this conference because
your focus area is on the societal
issues related to information usage and
specifically the collection of consumer
data and particularly the collection of
unlighted
on sorry I said that wrong online
targeted behavioral data that allows
specific bespoke marketing to happen so
her whole work area has focused on a
question of targeted advertising and the
ways in which targeted advertisements
impact socially on consumers and on
publishers
so she has an analytical model that
analyzes the impact of targeted
advertisements on consumer welfare and
I'd love to see that numerical model for
dealing with welfare because that's an
important topic so let's please roll the
video for Veronica in one of my projects
I developed a framework to understand
the role of personal data in the context
of online targeted advertising and
within this context I analyzed how their
location of benefits among consumers and
industry players would change when
different policy interventions that can
restrict how many and which consumer
data can be collected and used are
actually implemented in the market and
the results of the analysis highlights
the existence of an incentive
misalignments among the players in that
the policy intervention that who
maximized the industry profit for
example can vastly differ from the
policy intervention that will maximize
consumers benefits and so this creates a
tensions among these two set of players
because depending on the underlying
market structure different police
interventions are going to lead to very
different allocations of benefits the
existence of this trade-off between
consumers interest and the industry
interest under certain circumstances but
not in all the cases calls for policy
interventions that are tailored rather
than a uniform or Omni comprehensive so
for example under certain conditions the
market by itself can lead to an outcome
that is optimal for most of the players
if not for all of them but in other
situations when there is a complete miss
alignments of interest among the players
then there may be the need for a
policymaker to intervene either to
protect the consumers or to protect the
industry depending also on the objective
of the policy in another of my projects
I designed an experiment to investigate
the impact of blocking social media
interruptions on individuals performance
and the experiment was implemented by
using
Digital application so an app that
allowed us to block the access to
specific social media websites for a
group of individuals and the results of
the experiment
indeed suggest that the average social
media user could benefit from
technologies to limit
such social media interruptions in that
in our experiment participants
experienced a significant improvement in
their performance so for example they
completed a significantly higher number
of working tasks per hour compared to
individuals for whom we didn't block
social media interactions so in the same
experiment we also add a second group of
individuals that was given the
application and left free to use it so
choose which social media websites to
block him for how long and the objective
was exactly try to investigate whether
individuals when letting control can
impose restrictions on their home
behavior and the result of the
experiment suggests that individuals may
not be able to do so either for a lack
of motivation in using such technologies
or for a lack of self control that may
somewhat limit their ability to impose
restrictions on their own browsing
behavior I think it's completely
fascinating that access can disempower
because that's not usually how we think
and Veronica's research is outstanding
at showing that nuanced so I'd love to
sit with her now and have a little
discussion that's not gonna go well all
I can do is play video again so instead
let's have a coffee break and at 4:30
sharp we're gonna begin again and we
will have our introduction in keynote
speech by Eric Horvitz head of Microsoft
Research so we look forward to seeing
you then the coffee is in the back just
behind the gap in the wall see you soon
[Music]
you